is there some other stuff you remember
like the purple links there were some
interesting design decisions there to
kind of come up that uh we have today or
we don't have today that were temporary
so uh we made I made the background I
hated reading text on white uh uh
backgrounds and so I made the background
correct everybody do you regret no you
go ahead no no no that's that decision I
think has been reversed uh but but now
I'm happy though because now dark mode
is the thing so so it wasn't about gray
it was just he didn't want white
background strain my eyes
change your eyes interesting
um and then there's a bunch of other
decisions I'm sure there's an
interesting history of the development
of HTML and CSS and all those and
interface and JavaScript and there's
this whole Java applet thing
well the big one probably JavaScript CSS
was after me so I didn't that was not me
but um JavaScript was the big JavaScript
maybe was the biggest of the whole thing
that was us
um and um and that was basically a bet
it was a bet on two things one is that
the world wanted a new front-end
scripting language
um and then the other was we I thought
at the time the world wanted a new
back-end scripting language
um so JavaScript was designed from the
beginning to be both front end and back
end
and then it failed as a back-end
scripting language and uh Java one for a
long time and then python Pearl and
other things PHP um and Ruby but now
JavaScript is back and so I wonder if
everything in the end will run on
JavaScript it see it seems like it is
the um and by the way let me give a
shout out to uh to um uh uh Brendan Ike
uh was the uh basically the one-man
inventor of um of JavaScript if you're
interested to learn more about Brandon
Knight he's been on this podcast
previously exactly so he wrote
JavaScript over a summer um and it I I
mean I think it is fair it is fair to
say now that it's the most widely used
language in the world and it seems to
only be gaining in in um in its uh in
its range of adoption in the software
world there's quite a few stories of
somebody over a weekend or over a week
or over a summer writing some of the
most uh impactful revolutionary pieces
of software ever well look that should
be inspiring yes very inspiring I'll
give you another one SSL
um so SSL was the security protocol that
was us and that was a crazy idea at the
time which was let's take all the native
protocols and let's wrap them in a
security wrapper that was a guy named
Kip Hickman who wrote that over a summer
uh one guy
um and then look today sitting here
today like the transformer like at
Google was a small handful of people and
then you know the number of people who
left did like the core work on GPT it's
not that many people it's a pretty small
handful of people
um and so yeah the pattern in software
repeatedly over a very long time has
been it's it's a Jeff Jeff Bezos always
said the two Pizza rule uh for teams at
Amazon which is any team needs to be
able to be fed with two pieces if you
need the third Pizza you have too many
people and I I think that's I think
that's I think it's actually the one
pizza rule yeah for the for the really
creative work I think it's two people
three people well that's you see that
with certain open source projects like
so much is done by like one or two
people
it's it's so incredible and that's why
you see that gives me so much hope about
the open source movement in this new age
of AI
where um you know just the reason they
haven't had a conversation with with
Mark Zuckerberg of all people who's all
in on open source which is so
interesting to see
and so inspiring to see because like
releasing these models it is scary it is
potentially very dangerous and we'll
talk about that
but it's also
if you believe in the goodness of most
people and in the skill set of most
people and the desire to do good in the
world that's really exciting because
it's not putting it these models into
the centralized control of big
corporations the government and so on
it's putting it in the in the hands of a
teenage kid with like a dream in his
eyes I don't know that's um
that's beautiful and look this stuff AI
ought to make the individual coder
obviously far more productive right by
like you know a thousand X or something
and so you ought to be open source like
the not just the future of Open Source
AI but the future of Open Source
everything we ought to have a world now
of super coders right who are building
things as open source with one or two
people that were inconceivable you know
five years ago
um you know the level of kind of hyper
productivity we're going to get out of
our best and brightest I think is going
to go way up